and L just just uh finalized uh we'll
learn more about the context of meeting
then we'll have a Q&A we'll first hear
from the Madame
chairwoman Miss
K thank
you and good day dear media
Representatives warm welcome from my
side um at the start of the press
conference uh let me to uh allow me to
welcome Madame President of the Europe
commission a dear friend of BOS and
heroina dear urula
welcome it is indeed a
pleasure and I would like to use the
opportunity to note how pleased I am to
host Madame President in boszina after
her Regional
tour to welcome her in the uh premises
of the institutions of bosan heroina as
a represented ative of the Executive
Branch the national level this visit
indeed is an important step on the
country's obession path but um above
all let me note that today's visit is an
opportunity to showcase the new growth
plan of the European Union for the
countries of the region I would also
like to note that um this is
um of great importance for all of us and
we should all um make use of the
opportunity in the region as well as in
bovina to make uh leaps uh forward uh
under the framework of the growth uh
plan uh which U provides uh conditions
uh to improve the living standard of um
all our citizens but not just living
standards to improve infrastructure
connectivity and freedom of movement of
goods and services and yes this visit
um is an opportunity for us to learn
more about the growth plan or to learn
more about the uh decision uh made by
the European Union on the financial
assistance in the amount of6 billion
euros for the countries of the region of
which two million uh two billion are uh
grants uh and
four different uh types of uh loans um
we express uh our gratitude to the EU
and institutions for their
assistance and um the actual
implementation and absorption of the
funds will be entirely in our own hands
and this is very important to understand
in countries such as bosnan and heroina
the new growth
plan
is also a commitment of the Council of
ministers a
commitmen to deliver on all remaining uh
conditionalities uh um including uh uh
completion of the regional Common Market
implementing the necessary reforms uh
and
um increasing pre
accession assistance um we also made use
of today's meeting to discuss the
results of the Council of ministers in
the past 10 months in office and it's
difficult to list um each
and every deliverable to properly
summarize all the activities on our
reform path but uh I tried to rely on
the numbers and I'll do the same here we
had 40 sessions uh of the Council of
ministers regular and extraordinary over
over 1,300 materials were reviewed
including uh laws
legislation ordinances different
decisions strategies reports decisions
on the functioning of the SAA committee
Etc all the results the accession
path include reforms in the field of
Human Rights
rule of
law functionality and
democracy anti-corruption
combating organized crime and aligning
our foreign and security policy with the
common foreign security policy of the EU
where in fact we have
100%
alignment they remain
committed while at the same time
understanding that bosnan and heroina
is um yet to see the country report to
be presented um on November 8th but um
based on the deliverables I'm convinced
that Madame President president together
with her Associates I express our
gratitude to her Associates for their
assistance uh um for the helping hand
and understanding for the progress that
we've been making on the EU path that uh
we will be eventually encouraged with
the opening of the
negotiation uh process and the opening
would mean a great deal to to the
country the candidate status granted
last year had was a major contributor to
stabilizing the situation the
institutions the political arena in
general and and the uh opening of negot
negotiations alike in the overall uh
geopolitical context and developments
would be a boost for the country to um
be truly peaceful and prosperous and
stable Society to work on whatever is in
the best interest of our citizens rather
than um focus on divisions and pasts and
things that do not benefit anyone in
this uh country at the same
time such approach would help us deliver
on the excession path and bring us a
step closer towards the the final
goal just to note that the assistance
that the EU institutions have been Pro
providing uh is um remarkable all the
deliverables um have been achieved
together in Partnership um with the EU
representatives and Associates and with
Madame President uh herself and as I
said the opening of negotiations would
truly be a boost for everyone in the
country to make the necessary
steps the developments in bosina
inevitably reflect um on the rest of the
region and vice versa they they have
their reflection on not just
developments in the society but the work
of the institutions and in general
developments in the region reflect on
the developments in the EU so once again
thank you to the Madame
President I believe we jointly remain
committed to our common goal meaning uh
accession path a step closer to
full-fledged membership as a chairwoman
the Council of minister commited I will
continue working
tirelessly to deliver on the commitments
in the interest and of all of us you are
well aware that any progress in this
country is um highly dependent on
dialogue mutual respect and
understanding and respect for the
Constitutional and legal setup we also
remain committed to the
regional initiatives uh and uh the even
the new growth plan comes with the
conditionalities that we need to deliver
on um as for the Berlin process we still
have one pending agreement left to
absorb the funds of the growth plan um I
can speak on behalf of the institutions
that we will do our best or whatever it
takes for the
country to meet this conditionality I've
also used the opportunity to informed
The Madame President that we were in the
uh final stages uh of reaching an
agreement on certain laws and policies
that were much uh needed um we still
needed that uh final uh push but
um we continue working till the end of
the year till the end of our term uh in
in office uh on the accession path of
bosan heroina thank you Madame President
Wonder to take the
floor
for
positive
[Music]
for
B
uh
for
thank you we are open for questions uh
uh two or three
questions haat TV my first question for
Madame President uh V
derland the ruling parties but your OPP
position as well are expecting
um possible decision on the opening of
negotiations on come December
15th uh will it be necessary for the
country to adopt the three key laws the
Law Courts law conflict of interest and
the anti-money laund laundering law is
this a conditionality and the question
for Madame kristo can we expect these
laws to be adopted by December
15th yes thank you for your
question concerning the adoption of the
reform laws uh that are essential for
the country to deliver on the key
priorities uh laid by the uh European
commission when it comes to the conflict
of interest the law on courts the
anti-money laundering and also decision
on frontex if I may add these are almost
finalized we needed perhaps uh one or
two more sessions uh for to reach the
finish uh line as for anti-money
laundering uh we have a draft proposal
finalized at the level of the working
group haven't collected the opinions yet
but it should be finalized soon I
wouldn't like us
to be hunger by dates whether it's 15th
December or not uh as a government uh we
remain committed continuously to work on
reforms and reach agreement and
consensus at the level of the Council of
uh ministers uh to to implement or to
amend legis in line with the EU values
and standards that we remain committed
to
[Music]
for
question for Madam president U Vander
and we are all interested to learn more
details uh about the growth plan how is
this uh financial assistance uh to be
distributed across the region what is
the envelope for bosnan and Herzegovina
to plan to have additional
conditionalities on top of what was
mentioned by Madame krisha and yes there
there was also a ban uh by the European
commission when it comes to certain
projects in Republic Suba because of
some developments and rhetorics and with
the growth plan can all governments
count on
assistance
Next
[Music]
Generation
can we have uh one more question last
question because we are running
late can we have order please this is uh
Madame President of the European
commission RDR Mr
shots please let's stay
civilized TV of Republic sska TV very
simple question for our dear guest is it
possible for BOS andina
to be a full-fledged member state to
have the open negotiations with a
foreign
International um at the office of the
high representative and when
International judges the Constitutional
Court which is also one of the 14 key
priorities
this concludes today's press uh
conference thank
[Music]
you